the style of the way gpt4 talks to you
yes really matters you probably want
something different than what I want but
we both probably want something
different than the current gpt4
and that will be really important even
for a very tool-like thing
is there styles of conversation oh no
contents of conversations you're looking
forward to with an AGI like GPT
567 is there stuff where
like where do you go to outside of the
fun meme stuff for actual I mean what
I'm excited for is like
please explain to me how all the physics
works and solve all remaining Mysteries
so like a theory of everything I'll be
real happy
faster than light
travel don't you want to know
so there's several things to know it's
like and and be hard uh is it possible
and how to do it
um yeah I want to know I want to know
probably the first question would be are
there other intelligent alien
civilizations out there but I don't
think AGI has the not the ability to do
that to do to know that it might be able
to help us figure out how to go detect
and meaning to like send some emails to
humans and say can you run these
experiments can you build the space
probe can you wait you know a very long
time or provide a much better estimate
than the Drake equation yeah uh with
with the knowledge we already have and
maybe process all the because we've been
collecting a lot of yeah you know maybe
it's in the data maybe we need to build
better detectors which that and it
really Advanced technically tell us how
to do it may not be able to answer it on
its own but it may be able to tell us
what to go build
to collect more data what if it says the
aliens are already here
I think I would just go about my life
yeah probably
uh because I mean a version of that is
like what are you doing differently now
that like if if gpt4 told you and you
believed it okay AGI is here
or AJ is coming real soon
what are you going to do differently the
source of joy and happiness of
fulfillment in life is from other humans
so it's mostly nothing right unless it
causes some kind of threat
um but that threat would have to be like
literally a fire like are we are we
living now with a greater degree of
digital intelligence than you would have
expected three years ago in the world
yeah and if you could go back and be
told by an oracle three years ago which
is you know blink of an eye that in
March of 2023 you will be living with
this degree of digital intelligence
would you expect your life to be more
different than it is right now
probably probably but there's also a lot
of different trajectories intermixed I
would have expected the um society's
response to a pandemic
uh to be much better
much clearer
less divided I was very confused about
there's there's a lot of stuff given the
amazing technological advancements that
are happening the weird social divisions
it's almost like the more technological
investment there is the more we're going
to be having fun with social division or
maybe the technological advancement just
revealed the division that was already
there but all of that just make the
confuses
my understanding of how far along we are
as a human civilization and what brings
us meaning and what how we discover
truth together and knowledge and wisdom
so I don't I don't know but when I look
I when I open Wikipedia
I'm happy that humans are able to create
this thing yes there is bias yes it's a
triangle it's a Triumph of human
civilization 100 uh Google search the
search search period is incredible what
he was able to do you know 20 years ago
then and now this this is this new thing
GPT is like is this like gonna be the
next like the conglomeration of all of
that that made uh web search and
Wikipedia so magical but now more
directly accessible you have a
conversation with a damn thing it's
incredible